[Music]  do you ever feel weird weird sometimes I  feel like I'm always on the outside  there's this invisible line that I have  to cross to really be a part of  everything and they just can't ever  cross it me too  my name's Simon I'm just like you except  I have one huge ass secret I said I like  your boots  bye nobody knows I'm gay sometimes I  feel like I'm stuck on a ferris wheel  [Music]  one minute I'm on top of the world  [Music]  in the next cement rock-bottom  I've been thinking about why I haven't  come out yet maybe part of me wants to  hold on to who I've always been  just a little longer  [Music]  [Music]  no matter what announcing who you are to  the world is pretty terrifying because  what if the world doesn't like you  PS doesn't seem fair that only gay  people have to come out - straight to  default I have something I need to tell  you I like girls he's trying to kill me  I like men  I'm straight  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you